I don't know if you noticed this during
the first drive of the Rams Saints game
there was a moment where suddenly the
camera went off the field and just
showed a shot out of nowhere of the
Superdome and at the time I had no idea
what was happening I thought like our
aliens invading like and then it was
right back you know during the game
again something I had never seen it
turns out that Fox was actually trying
to save us from seeing Saints wide
receiver Michael Thomas's but that his
pants were being pulled down and then
someone you know cut to a different shot
so that America would not have to see
Michael Thomas's but see this is why
they call it the no fun league all right
tune in to games you want to see Michael
Thomas's but you want to see some
buddies but you know if it's if it's but
like it's like if you take your helmet
off on the field you're getting a flag
but if your helmet gets knocked off it's
all good fun you know that's like the
best place yeah so I think if you moon
someone on the field it should be a flag
but if you just get your pants pulled
down in the line of duty
then everyone should be able to enjoy
that you know and and secondly is there
someone whose job it is like this has
happened like twice in the history of
the NFL that someone's job is just like
we're about to see some but whoever it
is they should get him raised cuz I mean
they were on top of things that the it
was barely getting pulled down like you
saw like a half half a crack or whatever
and they were on another shot so he's a
or she is on top of it do you think
Michael Thomas planned this do you think
it was kind of like like tío in the
Sharpie I think like when or even when
Michael Thomas yep
parked at a cell phone first touchdown
celebration this is just like another
wide receiver looking for attention is
this such a big problem by the way that
that it is someone's job I mean that I
just mean like this doesn't this doesn't
happen too often they were so quick with
it that it must be like not only
someone's job but like a real fear at
the NFL that you're gonna see someone's
but you know maybe it's maybe it's still
fall back off from the Janet Jackson
thing do you think it was a white player
they wouldn't have cut away they would
assume done is racist do you think they
would I think they were too zoomed in on
his but there was a white player I'm
gonna say it right now the NFL's racist
I think it's it's probably I mean who
doesn't
who wouldn't want it like wouldn't you
want to see like wouldn't your the
chance of like you continuing to watch
go up slightly if you had a chance to
just randomly see Michael Thomas's but
every game it's the only reason how much
football just try to see your players
but going over the gold money it is one
of the reasons that the NFL is more
popular than other sports women women
love it men love like everyone loves it
when the accident except the NBA the no
but Association I want to say I mean you
should be able to see his but if you buy
ticket if I mean that invested I've
owned the teams all year and they pulls
pants down no one no one even asked him
afterwards like why don't you wear
underwear on the field you're just gonna
free ball under your pads which is
insane
you should get to see full but speaking
abut this next story yeah also in
football where Tiki Barber crawled out
of wherever he's been hidin made his
Broadway debut this week in kinky boots
yeah that's it's just I don't know what
kinky boots is I've heard the name I
haven't seen a been around a long time
yeah I've only seen one Broadway show I
think in the past 20 years and that was
um was the South Park guys Book of
Mormon yeah which I'm sure but I cannot
stand musicals otherwise a Hamilton get
the out of here with Hamilton you
never saw it so I mean I would like it
no but I've heard the soundtrack and I'm
just like oh my god I can't believe
anyone says this is hip-hop or rap or
anything it it disgusts me and I hear
it's historically inaccurate but Tiki
Barber made his Broadway debut and kinky
boots and like listen I just want to
talk about the story because of how far
Tiki Barber has fallen I mean this is a
guy who was the starting running back
for the New York Giants when they were a
real team and retired in his prime to
pursue other things like life is more
than football afterwards the Giants won
not one but two Super Bowls immediately
after it's not only that but he he
antagonize Tom Coughlin so aggressively
during his last season in the NFL saying
he didn't you know like Tom Coughlin
that he was kind of shunned during this
whole Super Bowl run
they didn't even wanna you know
acknowledged that he was this former
great player yeah they hated him and as
soon as he left they were every one of
the Giants want a ring and then he begin
when would Today Show Good Morning
America Today Show and okay had this big
like blitz and I remembered the quote
being like you know what someday they're
gonna point to him and be like you know
he used to play football and then within
a year he a camera wouldn't not go
anywhere near him he totally bombed out
of Good Morning America he was a jerk my
show today bombed out of this Today Show
never got going anything else nobody
wanted to see him and the Giants just
took off and now Michael Strahan he's
like the anti Michael Strahan because
Strahan retired after winning a couple
Super Bowls and then has been a god on
morning television has made all the
money the Tiki Barber's got to be
completely miserable I feel like there
is a movie to be made here that Michael
Strahan essentially took Tiki Barber's
life the life that he wanted and an left
barber in ruins because they were huge
rivals while they were on the team like
they famously went after each other in
the media at one point barber was kind
of saying that Strahan should be quiet
and not ask for more money and like the
media and the fans all took Tiki Barber
side like it's some sort of
Shakespearean stuff that at all like
Strahan had all this ugly divorce stuff
in the papers but in the end it was Tiki
Barber who ended up kind of being like
this tabloid fodder because he left his
pregnant wife for a Today Show intern
I'm doing some research for this show
I've done research I'm still stuck on
you saying it's Shakespearean I'm just
saying the right it's it's if you told
me that Strahan like that this was all
of his plan the entire time was like
setting Tiki Barber up to fail and then
he was gonna go out on a Super Bowl and
then he was gonna have the career barber
had like because Tiki Barber a talk
to him back in 2002 about his divorce
and contract like that wouldn't surprise
me what would you rather have would you
rather have a long lasting and prolific
career in television or a twin brother
identical twin brother what's better
I would I would take the career I would
take the brother you take Ron day I
would I would love an identical twin
brother I was I wanted to get back to
the research I was doing here
because when this this internship
scandal happened that it turned out he
was cheating on his wife with like a 23
year old like tall blond intern from
from wherever he was working
broadcasting who Strahan or Tiki Barber
Tiki Barber he was quoted very
unapologetic totally about it saying
that it was like a reverse and Frank
thing because he was hooking up with
this intern in the Attic of her parents
house and he called it a reverse and
Frank I was like I can't believe I
didn't hear about this and that
apparently was also bad PR for him too
yeah let's go to let's talk a little
Patriots shall we yeah the only thing I
liked by the Patriots is this Donald
Trump our president congratulated the
Patriots after their AFC Championship
game on Twitter but he did not say
anything about the Rams no don't run was
knew anything about football
he likes the Patriots because the
Patriots like Trump Belichick 100% for
sure voted for Trump craft 100 100
percent sure voted for Trump Tom Brady
100 percent there's no doubt voted for
Trump
ah Belichick wrote him a letter after he
won wrote the president a letter Tom
Brady had to make America great again
hat in his locker and was like oh no I
think it'd be cool it'd be fun if he was
I was way before that he's tried to
distance him he's tried to and he's
failed because he's not distant because
he's right in there he loves him Tom
Brady wishes he could kiss Donald Trump
I think of Robert Kraft Tom Brady and
Bill Belichick could get Donald Trump
into a closet it would be the best seven
minutes in heaven of all time that's why
I love it as successful as they are
they'll be remembered know as the
players who when Colin Kaepernick and
all these players were trying to go and
and make things better for for for black
people in this country and minorities in
this country by the way Martin Luther
King would have wanted
you got Brady Kraft and Bella check on
the other side pushing as hard as they
can to keep the status quo right where
it is I don't know how you
even root for them Pat the Patriot voted
for Trump I don't like to get political
but these guys did it for me Robert
Kraft it gave Vladimir Putin a Super
Bowl ring ticket collusion that's what
that's what Kraft says now he's trying
to distance himself no they are in the
tank there Belichick Kraft and Tom Brady
are like my parents Brady didn't show up
to the White House when Trump had him
there and people were always equipment
worked up about that he probably showed
up later on that night to just hang out
any KFC your quarterbacks a joke
[Music]
you